大家把眼睛闭上 认真听我下面说的话
窮人会吓疑时的用自己的时间去换钱
比如他想专钱呢
他首先想到的是 找个班上
加班 结个单 做个服务业
用自己的时间去换钱
因为他的时间都送来换钱了
所以他更没有时间去思考
更重要的事
这是一个思许问
副人 习惯或者吓疑时的会花钱买时间
所以他会购买别人的时间
别人的经验
别人采过的坑 系统和工具
从而可以接受大量的时间用来思考更重要的事
选择大于努力
这也是一个正相许问
那么我们到底该怎么发生改变呢
两部
第一部好好思考
我刚才说的话
一定是思微线改变
然后你的行动才会坚定不一的改变
第二部 具体的行动啊
那怕你再忙
每天花点时间看看
你经常重复的楼做事那些
花点时间去购务店一块产品一号
摩扬一号 流程一号 无论是什么
工具能够帮你接省哪怕一点电视频
因为他是重复的
所以哪怕每天可以帮你接省
帮要是不行二十分钟
哪怕十分钟
那么接省出来的时间干满呢
所以我说思微线一定会改变
一定要改变
当你每天可以接省出一些时间的时候
主要比一个
你可以把接省时间的工具卖给付人
你放心 复人下一次的
一定会花钱卖
接省时间的事
第二
这样就不会把你的时间浪费在赚钱上
因为你已经有了一套
不需要花时间就可以赚钱的事了
比如说那个不过吧
那个工具啊
那个系统啊
那个书啊 你拿我来说
不是我把我的一些经验接省书了
那我的稿费就注意直省
我就我至少可以让我
不用在
一定要花时间才能赚钱了
这样我就可以证到一些钱
那么拿这些钱
我可以购买别人的时间
别人采过的窗
别人的经验
替统或者工具来帮我接省
更多的时间用来思考
工作的事